je crois que stéphane tu l'as bien
résumé pour retrouver de la
compétitivité pour notre agriculture
c'est un arrêté là sur transposition des
normes françaises et deuxième étage de
la fusée
c'est les normes européennes et là je me
tourne vers angélique de la députée
européenne qui va nous dire un petit mot
sur ces fameuses normes européennes oui
alors je crois que ça a été dit par
ailleurs je veux dire mes collègues
parce que moi je suis je suis resté
agricultrice tout en étant député
européen parce que je crois que c'est
important de garder dépit sérieusement
ancrée seul terrain ça permet de faire
avancer aussi la réflexion les normes
européennes
elles valent pour les agriculteurs des
28 états membres et moi j'étais très
surprise de buch au parlement européen a
côtoyé des collègues qui sont eux aussi
agriculteur en allemagne en autriche ou
ailleurs je les entends pas ce se poser
les mêmes questions
vis-à-vis des normes européennes alors
évidemment on dit tous la même chose
simplification administrative est
d'ailleurs le commissaire hogan s'est
engagé sur une réforme de la
simplification de des mesures
d'application de la pac
très bien on attend de voir quand même à
chaque fois qu'on parle de
simplification moi j'ai quelques doutes
parce qu'on met un contrôle
supplémentaire donc en règle générale ça
fait pas toujours de la simplification
enfin on sera en tous les cas en tant
que député vigilant sur cette question
là moi je vais prendre trois trois
exemples très concrets pour ne pas
allonger le débat sur cette question la
déclaration pac
moi j'ai posé la question mais que l'est
puis si je rentre je remplis de
déclarations puisque le mon mari ne
voulant pas remplir la sienne c'est moi
qui me la cogne et puis je remplis la
mienne voilà donc c'est une lentille à
chaque mois puis alors cette année ça a
été le pont va l'année dernière c'était
le pompon et donc
je dis à mon collègue allemand jeudi
bègue comment tu fais toi pour ta
déclaration pac à 1010 mots nous on a
deux mesures de page nous on a dit cette
mesure voilà et ça c'est pas la pac 1
c'est ici en france qu'on a décidé de
mettre ça en place
donc là aussi il faut travailler au plan
européen pour que les choses ne
s'alourdisse pas si elles peuvent même
salle et j'ai ma foi c'est tant mieux
mais il faut aussi qu'on soit très
vigilant ici ici et je le dis devant mes
collègues agriculteurs c'est autant la
faute des politiques de l'administration
que de la profession parce que c'est la
subsidiarité
c'est la subsidiarité qu'on a laissé à
chaque état pour régler des problèmes
locaux et en france ça s'est traduit par
10 cette mesure donc je dis on est tous
collectivement responsable voilà
deuxièmes et deuxième exemple et là il
est alors là celui là 100% français
l'europe a décidé de s'inquiéter de la
sécurité des jeunes travailleurs et a
dit eh bien il faut mettre en place des
dispositifs pour protéger les jeunes
salariés qui travaillent en automne
particulièrement les apprentis très bien
ça s'est traduit comme en nos collègues
allemands très pragmatique on dit à
partir de trois mètres il ya
effectivement dangerosité donc il faut
mettre des systèmes en place et nous en
france on a dit et bain dès qu'on est au
dessus du sol
on travaille en hauteur oui résultat on
peut plus mettre un apprenti sur un
escabeau qui fait de marche
voilà troisième exemple qui nous touche
en tant qu'agriculteur directive
nitrates stéphane ya fait allusion tout
à l'heure en europe c'est 50
milligrammes par litre en france s est
traduit par 18
donc effectivement on part déjà avec un
boulet à chaque pied résultat la france
entière va être en zone vulnérable et
donc on crée des contraintes
supplémentaires aux agriculteurs voilà
au travers ces trois exemples
je voulais vous montrer le travail qu'on
a affaire au plan européen mais aussi le
ménage à faire qu'on à faire
collectivement profession politique et
administration pour alléger la barque de
l'agriculture